David Shands welcome back to the think
media podcast uh in episode one we
talked all about uncommon ways to make
money in the crater economy but in this
episode we're going to be breaking down
how you built the studio for 750 000
which is the biggest sticker price good
for the YouTube thumbnail and for the
podcast title
um but that's not just an opulent Studio
that's a studio that you can rent out
that you can use to monetize generate
Revenue there's tax benefits even if
someone's listening to this and they're
a beginner this will change their
thinking this is about elevating their
thinking going to a whole other level
and we're going to talk about some of
the details but I want to take it back
um you did not get here overnight in
fact you I'm sure started super early
but let's let's pick up the story at the
Cheesecake Factory like what were you
doing at the Cheesecake Factory serving
of the server at the Cheesecake Factory
dude so was I I was a Red Robin server
really yeah so there's something about
tips oh come on man people skills oh
people skills are 100 you know what the
cruel the coolest thing is when I
stopped getting so frustrated with my
job and I started to like really try to
think of why I'm there yeah the job
became a lot more enjoyable and I made
more money so I would come to work and
playing in oh my gosh I want to be here
is my shift going to be over
um people are stiffing me on tips but
once I realized that I would one day
speak around the world and I wanted to
be a communicator
and I wanted I wanted to learn how to
sell a product right so I would start
selling the dishes and I would I would
be unsatisfied with myself if the person
didn't get cheesecake at the end of the
meal because I'm trying to acquire this
skill even if they gave me a great tip
but they didn't order cheesecake at the
end I was pissed because why couldn't I
sell they came to the Cheesecake Factory
why couldn't I sell them A Slice of
Cheesecake and once once I adopted that
my job became a lot more fun I started
making a lot more money and that's when
I began to exit out because I started
acquiring certain skills yeah and you're
thinking big in small places you were
thinking about getting the skills for
the next season and your journey so then
did entrepreneurship start next oh no I
was always an entrepreneur well uh when
was what was the move from Cheesecake
into the neck well what was the side
hustle during cheesecake a million of
them okay I always was doing something
to sell money to to make some money but
what changed for me was when I stopped
trying to like Chase the money I started
building this t-shirt brand called Sleep
Is for Suckers geared towards
entrepreneurship and anyone's willing to
lose sleep to get what they want yeah
and that was I realized that the reason
that I never really made any money any
side hustles is because I didn't give
the seeds long enough to grow
I'll start making some money and one of
the worst things you can do is make a
little bit of money because people come
to you with opportunities like yo you
can do this I'm like oh I'll do that
cool I'm gonna take the money from this
and put it in and I said I'm not going
to do any other business but these
t-shirts and that's it and once I like
got that staying power saying I'm gonna
I'm gonna lock into this that's when I
was able to leave two and a half years
later so the mistake people make is they
just pivot too much they make like two
bucks in affiliate marketing but then
they switch niches it's crazy they they
kind of get some momentum on a YouTube
channel and then they start something
else and they don't actually get the
momentum behind it okay so sleep is for
suckers t-shirt brand how many years did
you do that uh from 2010 I technically
still sell the shirts now but
um I started in 2010 and I left the job
2012. and so on the way over here uh our
Uber driver with Omar and I you know
because we're speaking tomorrow at
podcasters boot camp uh we uh mentioned
you and he didn't he said he didn't know
but outside we pulled up front and you
got a van a Mercedes Sprinter van
wrapped with your image and like you
know your your uh your license plate
says podcast that's what we do it's
legit
um and I saw you goes oh that guy used
to sell t-shirts at the mall yeah and so
uh he recognized you from that so that
was 2012 was kind of the sign and then
what'd you do next
um 2012 I opened the kiosk and then I
opened another kiosk in the same mall so
we had two kiosks in the same mall and
then were either standing like getting
people's attention yeah absolutely yes
Hawking Hocking the shirts yeah man no
yo it's to make money in a mall you have
to do that yeah because I know I know
when you go to the mall you try to act
like you don't see the guy in the middle
I know you try to act like you're on the
phone you're not you're just trying to
avoid being talked to and like we used
to go get them yeah yeah but it was it
was such a dope skill set to learn yeah
no doubt because if I didn't do that I
wouldn't eat yeah so so these kiosks are
happening from 2012 and Beyond when what
was the next pivot cool 2000 12 opened a
kiosk 2013 opened another kiosk in the
same mall 2014. I opened a store in
South DeKalb mall so about all three of
these running yeah I wasn't making any
money because I didn't understand
overhead and profit margin I don't want
to make it looked cool though
um but a few months into me like I built
out the store I get a loan for thirty
thousand dollars to build out the store
the mall says okay well a bigger store
DTLR downtown locker room they want your
space so you're gonna have to move
somewhere else
dang okay so that's when like it all
kind of came crashing down because like
right when I opened this store I'm like
all right I don't need the other kiosk
in tomorrow I'm gonna shut that down so
now I have a kiosk in them all in the
store and then the mall tells me they
have to like shut it down
but when that mall when that when that
store shut down that's when I was able
to finish my book um
and that was game changer for me okay
what's the book title dreams are built
overnight
how to create a bridge between your day
job and your daydream
if that mall didn't take the store I'd
probably still be in retail making ten
dollar profit per shirt but when I got
that when I got that book I'm like yo
this is amazing because people just buy
the book and the book is everybody size
in t-shirts if you don't have the shirt
size and color that you want at the
moment you're not gonna buy anything and
then like for shipping out you got to go
find the shirt size packet we can
pre-pack 100 books and just mail them so
that was amazing and then the book led
me into speaking I was on tour with uh
Eric Thomas for uh for a good little
while
and that led into my speaking led into
coaching and teaching and building
community and it just kind of kept
evolving and then 2018 you start a
podcast yes was that the thing no okay
what was before that well I start I'm
still like speaking and traveling and
coaching
the only reason I started the podcast
and I didn't know what the podcast meant
I didn't know what a podcast was
I said this genius idea like if Sean is
gonna speak it so I'm doing this
conference if Sean is going to speak at
the conference I got an idea I'll just
interview Sean and put it on YouTube if
people like that interview they'll come
to the conference to see Sean I'm like
oh geez so I started interviewing and
you'll see those early episodes it says
Hey guys May 4th make sure you come to
this make sure you come to the
conference right and uh yeah that's I
would do the podcast for that reason but
after the conference I wasn't
interviewing anybody because there was
no need to so they were like marketing
videos you thought about interviewing
somebody as a way to Market ahead of
time for an in-person conference in
2018. so the vision is evolving I mean
the theme here too is that it looks
today uh social proof podcast has had
millions and millions of down downloads
seven million the last year now it's a
million a month so that's 12 million a
year and climbing but at the time it did
not even start reverse engineering like
that it was just sleep is for suckers
it's no sleep no yeah for sure I'm like
if we got all these people there I have
the t-shirts there we'll sell t-shirts
oh yeah you sell books now at the
conference t-shirts at the conference
yeah you got and then were you uploading
those original marketing videos on
YouTube yeah they're still there okay so
what's crazy is the first like nine or
ten episodes you'll see I'm saying hey I
don't have a name for this podcast yet
but we'll name it later oh that's that
is punched here in the face and press
record I don't even have a name for this
podcast so you're listening to this
right now and you're like what's the
perfect name I'm trying to hire 99
designs to design my logo I'm trying to
get everything perfect and write my
whole plan which is fine but like
ultimately you didn't even name it this
is the no-name podcast audio is crazy
the videos and you started the channel
and you started RSS you started
uploading on audio as well yeah I mean
actually before that so Brandon I was
just here
what he I think he mentioned like okay
this we should just podcasting because
he's a videographer he's like just in
that space so he was recording me and he
was just uploading like clips of my
speeches on there so you'll still see
those on the chat they're all still
there and it's just like it's just clips
of speeches I don't know what that was
so so your YouTube channel goes back
pre-2018 with clips of speeches okay I
did a marketing video for the t-shirt
brand yeah that was really cool that was
beautiful so we got to check out that
the history there and so then uh when
did the social proof podcast get a name
and when did you kind of start getting
clarity about like what it is and how
powerful it could be
um well the conference was called social
proof but I didn't I didn't link them to
to get like I wasn't thinking like this
is a podcast I'm like I don't have a
name for this show I don't even think I
use the word podcast I don't have a name
for the show yeah so 2018 for the event
we're we're interviewing people and you
know we get people as a conference I
think we have like 550 people there but
I'm not podcasting in between so 2019
we're doing it again
and
uh we no 2000 was it 19 or 20. is it 19
or 20 when c19 hit that March was that
20 yeah yeah 20. so the next year like I
start podcasting or interviewing again
and leading up to this one of this next
event
but we had to do a virtual so it still
still turned out cool
um but I stopped it again
but then I saw this uh my guys earn your
leisure and they're just killing the
podcast space I'm like I'm doing what
they're doing too they're just more
consistent and he told me one day he's
like yo I like your show you're just not
consistent with it and I said at that
moment I'm going to be consistent we're
going to keep going so it was it was in
2020.
c19 happens and a circumstances happen
and you've had all this momentum up to
that time and you're like Now's the Time
I'm planning my flag it's time to get
consistent for sure on the wall here at
the studio it says consistency is the
cheat code the only cheat code oh it's
the only cheat code consistency is the
only cheat code down down upright a b a
b like it's the only one so uh and and
I've got a shout out that if um you want
a little bit more context around this we
did a whole studio tour
um and you can actually see the studio
tour almost 4 000 square feet
um and uh multiple podcast Studios and
so if you're listening to this on audio
highly recommend uh heading to YouTube
and getting that experience well course
link it in the show notes it's over on
the um you know main uh think media
channel but uh so then talk about now
you got some momentum on the podcast and
let's fast forward to the Genesis of
opening up the creators
Club House house the craters Club House
North Atlanta you get a vision I'm gonna
buy a building what are you doing like
sipping lemonade on your back porch are
you are you are you up because you don't
sleep sleep is for suckers is your
Instagram handle so are you just are you
just like I'm gonna buy a building like
what was how did you get the idea
um
I don't know like how do you like how do
you uh describe where a good idea comes
from
it's like it just it just hits you when
you're doing the thing so is it
Evolution yeah you have a home studio
was that yeah I have a yeah I mean at
first and then you were like I want no
so I have an event space me and my
partner Brandon we have an event space
that we opened in 2017 because the same
process happened we're thinking yo we
need a place to create content into
events because I'm doing events already
and I'm teaching and coaching how many
seats does that have that that building
is 4 000 square feet you know I show you
all tomorrow but it's literally down the
street okay and so and you rented that
one yes that's actually where that's
where
I was doing my first kind of like
podcast shows because I I still have the
studio yeah
um but you'll hear it like there's
there's an airport right there you'll
hear the planes fly over every single
episode flight path Omar I was saying
that like yeah yeah okay so it was the
evolution from that and it was a
decision to say I want to go bigger yeah
I mean that one we didn't own and I'm
just like yo I want to build out a place
where people can come do plug and play
podcasts and that was my original idea
like I'll set up all the studio stuff in
the studio and they just come in
plug up their SD card
hit record on the camera and they can
record their own podcast that was like
my initial thinking because my first
podcast that's what I did I would set up
the camera set up the audio hit record
come around and just do the interview
then when we're done we get up hit the
stop record so my I just want to set up
for people what I did for myself
initial thought so I'm like oh I need a
building but I didn't want to build out
a building that it that I didn't own
yeah but I didn't necessarily have the
money
to buy a whole building and I didn't
have my taxes so file your taxes y'all
it's easier to talk to the bank I didn't
have my yeah so you can show tax returns
exactly I got you nobody's giving me a
loan
so my friend was telling me about
creative financing opportunities where
it called owner seller financing we're
the owner of the building
plays the bank
yeah that's interesting so we got into
this deal
I saw what's crazy is once you start
looking for something stuff disappears
I'm driving around I'm actually I'm just
driving trying to find places I'm like I
don't know what got me in my car just
driving around and I see in the window
of this building owner financing I said
no way wow because you you've been
learning about it studying it and then
it was in the window obviously the owner
is speaking to somebody who knows what
that means 100 so you and maybe the sign
was there for a long time
but if you're not looking for something
you'll never see it
[Music]
this video is sponsored by streamyard
this is our go-to platform for live
streaming to YouTube and Facebook
especially when we have multiple people
joining us on a stream with an
incredibly easy to use interface for
doing cool transitions bringing in text
on the screen and seamlessly bringing on
guests this is the perfect platform for
the new and experienced creators alike
you can use the link that we have in the
description below to get 10 off
okay so you owner finance we talked
about this in the tour it was almost
500k correct and it was 10 you got them
down to 10 down he wanted 20. well shows
you can negotiate all kinds of other
things you got to be looking for
something even once you see it you don't
don't say don't give up if on the first
no yeah for sure keep negotiating price
is never the price the price is never
the price just because it's no no
doesn't mean no well in some cases it
does this is Louis Vuitton or something
yeah yeah yeah uh but but in terms of
business ethical business uh then if
somebody says no well hey what about
this you can keep uh you know
negotiating so you got them down to 10
which is like 50k yeah put down 50 000.
and then interest only for five years
which makes your payment twenty eight
hundred so you think about that now you
had to build it out but 2 800 a month
almost 4 000 square feet when listeners
of this podcast check out the the
YouTube video it's insane multiple three
podcast Studios yep three include mine
four for including yours which is just
yours so three that could be like rented
out or just multi-purpose multi-use and
then an event space for about 80 people
masterminds virtual events stage LED
wall and another 250k that you had to
put into it now that's Out Of Reach for
probably a lot of people but with super
intelligent is that you've been
compounding you were taking steps to
this you were selling T-shirts in the
mall and now and now here we are you
know yeah
um and so and it wasn't it wasn't like I
grabbed 250 000 and I dump it into the
building it was like
the the the the the whole let's say like
all the walls are going to be 70 000 and
they don't ask for the whole seventy
thousand it's like okay I've got to do
five thousand here two thousand here
three thousand here and I'm hustling I'm
grinding and I'm taking all the money
from my podcast and I'm dumping it into
this now did you refi yet or will you no
could you yeah of course because
literally I was I was just saying get it
appraised yeah I mean I could but I
literally just paid off the whole loan
last week oh congratulations yeah that's
that's amazing yeah yeah which was so
and so now you could actually go to a
bank if you want 100 uh get it appraised
and then get just a loan but would you
need to no you're just you're kind of
paying it down you're just paying it off
well no it's like I just paid the whole
thing because it's interest only I'm
paying us 2800 a month it doesn't touch
the 500 yeah yeah the principle and I I
I I did something like I did a um I did
some challenges and I I I'm working I
just hustling and I saved the money and
I just gave like 450 000. I think it's
kind of would you say this is true about
you I know it's true about me that
sometimes it's smart like
entrepreneurship is spelled r-i-s-k like
it is spelled risk now you have to make
smart risks but there's also something
about like lighting a fire and like that
sometimes you need that bigger goal so
of course you never want to bet the farm
it's going to kill you but but you do
want to stretch yourself so you you took
a risk you stepped out you got a loan
but did it not motivate it did you did
it light a fire so you could pay it down
did the interest payment even make you
feel like I got to do something so I'm
gonna pay this off as soon as possible
yeah absolutely absolutely but again I'm
still like hustling and I went and got
some revenue and I see the Money in the
Bank
so I'm like all right I'm just gonna
take all that money and just put it into
the building because I can always get
the money out yeah you could always get
cash yeah I can get 80 of the value out
yes me like just learning real estate so
I don't want to have just cash just
sitting there I'd rather be in this
building where it's almost like I'm
making another 2800 a month now yeah if
the money if the cash was just sitting
there but I can always go get it for
something else of course not a deal yeah
but and create more leverage so how how
much did saving on taxes come into part
of the strategy or was that not on your
mind well I don't know I mean just
write-offs in general obviously this is
all business you can write off the 250
000 of upgrades in gear only after you
open it uh so this is that we opened it
this year so I'm I'm interested to see
how my accountant and my tax planning is
going to affect this year yeah and and
then you can depreciate the building
correct correct and did you bonus to
appreciate it I don't know okay so but
but you could depreciate it over 27.5
probably at least so then that's the
other piece I mean is that especially
for entrepreneurs content creators that
are creating more momentum you got to
get that Financial education got to of
the power of real estate this is why
because we're thinking about I mean one
of the I'm super grateful that you
brought me out to uh speak at your
podcasters boot camp but like for me and
Omar we're here more to learn uh and I
feel like we're getting more than we're
giving just to be here to learn from
what you're doing and to see it because
we also want to open up something like
this in Vegas we're trying to learn from
all kinds of different there's so many
different models it's the crater economy
you can be so creative
um but even we're we're talking about
leasing versus owning one of the reasons
why we want to buy a building is because
buying is where you get the depreciation
you get the best tax benefits in real
estate 100 by far so if you're
succeeding at any level and then not
only that
um even between now and the end of the
year it's Q4 at the time of recording
this we're also thinking like what do we
need to upgrade you always want to be
thinking about kicking that tax scan
like how can I reduce my tax liability
if you're Amazon they were running
negative for seven eight nine years why
because it's hyper growth it's
reinvesting every dollar back in the
business is that still your mentality
100 absolutely Grant Cardone says
something at The Mastermind we were both
at and really this is this is a major
reason why I paid it off because he said
you know I said he said I go out and I
go make money and I take all that money
and put it somewhere where I can't get
it easily so I dump it into real estate
he said I do that because if I see the
account Get Low it makes me hungry to go
make more money so like once I once I
like took that cash and and paid it off
I'm like yo I gotta come up with some
more money yeah I gotta go get it like
this you seeing money in your bank
account can get you kind of relaxed you
know what I mean so I don't I don't want
that feeling yeah but uh yeah the
depreciation is definitely a tax uh a
tax savings but I don't look at it as
this great thing I just happen to have a
cash I put it in to a vehicle that will
save me 2800 a month but it's always
there the real estate doesn't go
anywhere okay and so then now when this
opens unopened now but like as it if
it's running at full speed what are kind
of like the ballpark of what it costs to
run out of studio and what people can do
um two things one I think we do
the rooms were they like 125 an hour or
something like that
without an engineer but you still get
the audio equipment if you just want to
like set up in here and yeah 125 hour
has a great sound we got the sound
panels and all that kind of did you post
it on peer space Also uh we will I just
hired a manager to do that because I'm
not going to be able to manage that yeah
so he'll put it on peer space and um
event detective and Autos okay so all
the different apps as kind of like if
someone lists their Airbnb on Airbnb and
VRBO plus your own website correct and
then that would peer space could be good
for discoverability but your own website
there's no percentage that peerspace
would take it'd just be straight to you
yeah there's another one I want to like
touch on another point so we do like a
done for you where we'll do everything
for you including shoot it upload it
give you Clips to post upload on video
and audio and right now it's 5 000 a
month right
but I don't even know if I want to rent
it out and do the services for people
I really I'm really like leaning towards
all of these rooms are just Studios
where me and my team create content I
can bring on
content creators like an artist I can
sign you and say yo go on that studio
let's record let's put this stuff up
let's go on YouTube let's let's just
mash it and it's almost like a record
label buying a studio to make music for
their artists you know I mean I don't I
don't I don't I don't know I don't know
if I want to keep like renting it out
and stuff I just let's just be a monster
with creating content and focus on that
show you so it's still in the
visioneering stage to a point yeah I
don't know what's going on I just bought
it okay and uh and so your uh you've got
the three Studios you got the virtual
event space it may just be for you but
right now someone could rent it out
right now they can go on the website and
uh like how much for the virtual events
to 80 seats they could run a virtual
event they got the LED wall they could
teach on a Vibe yes vibeboard
um
was maybe like 350 an hour or something
like that or no we have like half days
and it comes with an engineer for the
audio and and playing on the the video
wall and switching and all that kind of
stuff how big is your team for it right
now dedicated to this space 13 14. well
well 13 14 total we got about five in
here on a regular one two three about
four on a regular basis so you're not
sure if you want to do the 5000 package
but if you did that means there'd be an
editor and almost like a YouTube and
audio podcast channel manager yeah we're
doing it now actually we have a client
now okay we're still in there so you
upload their YouTube and their podcast
audio and you title it and you put the
show notes in and so they come here and
they shoot you edit it's completely done
for you that's like white glove and so
they're able to show up do they solo
around or they bring in interviews
um yeah absolutely so however they want
to do it and I kind of give them a
consultation on what I think would work
for them and they'll come in maybe two
days a month
for two hour blocks where you do two and
then two so you have four for the month
but we try to get to about eight so that
you have four in the can and we'll make
sure we release something every single
week yeah so they got so they got that
weekly podcast all done a little bit of
so their strategy included got it got it
and then and then it'll be a matter
you'll see where it goes from here but
then it'll be a matter of scaling up
because you may you may even scale that
down or just keep that one client
because you just want to use it for your
own stuff you're thinking about
launching like a network
um I want to I just haven't figured it
out yet
because most value in a network is like
if I have sponsors that are like
sponsoring our show I take that money
and I put it into the other people on
the network but I don't know if I want
to get into that and I feel like I would
almost I don't use the word babysit but
I really gotta like cultivate these
podcasters and I don't know if I want to
take my eye off the ball of what I'm
doing
to go fulfill that part of the vision
yeah unless I partner with somebody and
they can be development and they focus
on that and I can kind of just do high
level strategy
so I want to get a final word from you
on kind of this entrepreneur Journey
because Creator economy Journey but a
couple resources that we have is one to
get the full experience definitely check
out in the show notes the walkthrough so
you can see this amazing studio and kind
of give some inspiration too if you've
done this in a part one there is your
seven different ways uncommon ways to
make money in the crater economy three
we had a great podcast and I mean again
no hype it was I think it's a favorite
podcast I've ever been on oh wow because
you also ask ask questions that were
kind of at a deeper more tactical level
um than anybody else has really ever
asked and it was actually my first time
sitting more relaxed in comfortable
chairs and we went almost two hours so
it was it was able to really get
tactical and so we'll uh we can link
that up as well so great resources But
ultimately you just shared this journey
from the Cheesecake Factory to the
craters Clubhouse
and it's been a long road uh your
Instagram handle is sleep is for suckers
and so like what would you say are the
core drivers core values or core
mindsets that made you or or that
created you that were the building
blocks of David Shands not not being
arrogant
I'm always knowing that there's
something else to learn
and I'm I just have a true hunger to be
a better person like in all my areas of
life so
we've got we've got some like we've got
some good downloads on the podcast but
it's not Joe Rogan so we suck you know
what I mean like like we we got we got a
lot of work to do yeah and I think when
when some people get certain success
they get
they start like uh buying into their own
hype and they stop growing like I gotta
I gotta keep growing because now that
we're at a level we've passed certain
people in the podcast space but we're
still it's like every time you get to
another level you're at the bottom of
Another Mountain you know what I mean
you look up like oh wow it's a lot
bigger I got a lot more to do so
um I would say um just kind of keeping
your ego in check
um building amazing relationships with
people just being a person that people
are okay being around people okay doing
business with
um being honest and upfront
um no one can say I've restore from them
or lied to them or try to get over but I
mean I think that's been huge
um and just continuing to go
not relying on I don't I don't rely on a
whole lot of people
we're going to go and I think my team
really appreciates that because they
know I'm not relying on them we're going
to get it done anyway I I know my team
is thinking yo this guy's gonna go there
I want to be there when it gets there so
like we just we just work we work really
really hard really intentionally we
respect everybody and um
that's pretty much it